[Music]
[Applause]
here at the FTTH council conference in
Amsterdam I'm talking with Enrique
Blanco of telefónica okay thank you for
talking to us today tell us about your
experiences of ftth deployment in Spain
so our spirits in this rain tambien
Sarah Mason we have been we have been
learning about processes we have been
learning about quality experience we
have been learning about customer
purchases women we have been learning
about how we can look to the customer
implementing an end-to-end approach so
we sir slowly because when we assert the
industry it is not ready so we have been
learning how we can build new models how
we can even create a new equipment
because in fact in Spain we are not
sailing after the age we are sailing
Wi-Fi experience so we have been working
in this later on we have been working in
the contained in the platform video that
we have been creating trying to offer
our customer and good quality because
for the FTTH in Spain the killer
application it is a video so look into
the customer defining processes have
been amazing and today we have more than
20 million of home passes we have more
than 5 million of customers or 50 th
connect yourself it is crazy so and we
are fully convinced that this is the
future we are pushing very hard and from
that experience that you've gained are
you transferring that into the sort of
the Latin region how's that going so one
Operator is telefónica so the main value
the main asset that we have it is the
knowledge so the knowledge of the people
that they are thinking in the customer
and learning about processes we decide
to build the industrialization of the
fiber production so we are a big machine
of fiber production and it means all the
knowledge that we have in Spain with the
teams and with the people coming from
Spain so working close as a single team
in Brazil working together it is the
same time you need to adapt something
specific for the country but more than a
90% have been how we can to migrate
faster so all the processes and all the
knowledge France painting Brazil we did
it and we we get one as so much your
operation in less than nine months
and we did it from the people of Brazil
doing for children Argentina so this is
how we understand a multinational
Stefania so and this had me helping us
to go faster with the quality that our
customer Gaskin so and this is how we
can migrate the knowledge team by team
trying to warranty that the maturity of
the product the quality of experience it
is a fact so we did it and in the in
Spain we we we spend more than two years
improving in Brazil we spend less than
nine months and in Chile we did it in
less than six months fantastic during
this process so as you're learning what
do you think are going to be the next
sort of technological challenges we are
in a change of cycle so we we have been
doing a big way for all the parameters
in the Poggi deployment we have doing a
vehicle for in the Jeep owned so
offering our customer one Giga then
exactly it is in the table so we are now
testing in and then we are finishing the
10 Jeep on offer in our customer 10
gigas our customer 10 gigas so and we
are being really trying to provide the
5g starting smoothly by the head but by
the hand of the use cases but this is
going to happen this is gonna be deploy
it in the country but we go back this is
about customers the customer they will
be asking for us new services at home
new video capabilities going to 4k to HK
go into augmented reality go into TV 360
so going to came in so and this is by
the hand of the technological cycle
pollution that we are living today it's
amazing doesn't matter what you're
offering your customer is you're
offering them quality they will be
asking for them
well good luck with keeping up with that
demand thank you very much for joining
us today thank you very much for the
opportunity
[Music]
[Applause]